la vaccination s'adapte au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
fini le méga centres situés sur l'air
central de la structure un mini centre a
ouvert ce 1er novembre sur le site
conséquence du ralentissement de la
vaccination en france ces dernières
semaines cd je crois que c'est un
facteur 10
si on retrouve toujours ce facteur donc
il ya dix fois moins
de vaccination aujourd'hui c'est
l'adaptabilité c'est la réversibilité
c'est l'agilité c'était une structure
comme qui s'est adapté je vous dis un
petit besoin comme au début et
aujourd'hui est un gros besoin la
structure est passé d'une vingtaine de
médecins sur l'air centrale à trois
boxes avec deux médecins et une
infirmière richard baudet présents sur
le site depuis mars dernier comprend
cette décision sont ça normal c'est bien
qu'on soit redescendue parce qu'on avait
beaucoup moins de travail donc on est
passé de plusieurs milliers à quelques
centaines donc
cette évolution me trouve je trouve ça
plutôt favorable et sympathique
aujourd'hui avec ce nouveau format le
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines peut vacciner
jusqu'à 300 personnes par jour voyez
peut-être vous êtes bus venus ce matin
que ça roule bien qu'il ya régulièrement
des patients qui viennent on n'a pas de
périodes d'attentes importante et on n'a
pas non plus d'affluence énorme grâce au
rendez-vous qui ont été pris et que les
gens respectent et bien tout se passe
bien ce nouveau mini centre est ouvert
du lundi au vendredi de 9h à 15h depuis
mars 2021 levé le tour national de saint
quentin en yvelines a vacciné plus de
350 mille personnes